pues básicamente lo que quiere reino
unido- es recuperar precisamente el
mercado de irlanda del norte a través
del establecimiento de dos canales un
canal verde para que todas las
mercancías bienes del reino unido- hacer
landa del norte no tengan que pasar por
ningún proceso aduanero o fitosanitario
y puedan ser consumidos de manera libre
en ese mercado y por el otro lado este
famoso canal rojo que son aquellas
mercancías procedente del reino unido
hacia la república de irlanda que forma
parte de la europea aunque estarían
sometidos precisamente a todos estos
protocolos aduaneros dicho esto entonces
lo que se estaría haciendo es recuperar
el importante mercado de irlanda del
norte para los bienes del reino unido- y
qué implicaciones podrían tener estas
modificaciones como se afecta el acuerdo
del break city
pues es una modificación sustancial más
allá de que el propio origen horizon se
había explicado de que son cuestiones
triviales en realidad esta negociación
que se alcanzó precisamente el protocolo
irlanda del norte dentro del bce es una
negociación compleja es una negociación
que se integra precisamente dentro del
propio deducir y que forma parte de todo
de todo un paquete lo que está haciendo
hoy johnson es de alguna manera vulnerar
estos acuerdos para el recuperar por un
lado estos mercados pero también
suspender la jurisdicción del tribunal
de justicia europeo sobre cualquier
disputa comercial que pueda surgir sobre
el mercado de irlanda del norte porque
al día de hoy este mercado se estaría
regulando precisamente por las normas
este y reglamentos de la propia unión
europea
por un lado quitaría estas normas
abriría a las propias normas del reino
unido y por el otro lado pondría la
jurisdicción de cualquier disputa a los
propios tribunales este obviamente del
reino unido
cuáles serían las consecuencias legales
que podría enfrentar reino unido
pues sin lugar a dudas es una violación
a un acuerdo que ya había sido negociado
que había sido aceptado que había sido
firmado por la por el propio reino
unido- y de esto estaría él tomando una
vía unilateral que evidentemente estaría
violando estos acuerdos internacionales
pero que también pudiera ser una medida
de presión si bien la unión europea ha
comentado que no va a dar marcha atrás
la unión europea pudiera tomar algún
tipo de sanciones económicas contra el
reino unido- lo cual evidentemente en
este momento tan tenso y de crisis en
general en europa sería muy mal momento